congratulations to the architect and the
mastermind behind this whole thing Kevin
Feige congratulations my friend it's
been so cool to watch and witness and
learn as I watch you and your team just
meticulously storyteller
over the years has just been really
incredible the biggest movie of all time
holy [ __ ] look what you did look what
you guys did Kevin Congrats and I know
our assistants have been trying to get
us together for dinner for months now
we're both super busy boys and I look
forward to our schedule linking up and
and that's it Congrats guys I'm gonna go
work out now and pretend to work out
rather and pour water on my head to
pretend to sweat because look it's all
smoking bears don't make it weird
Avengers congratulations oh you know
what I meant to say the best thing about
this whole thing is the fact that you
guys have sent the audience home happy
and floating with a very rare error a
plus CinemaScore a plus very rare
congratulations I'm all about audience
first and that's the best part about
this whole thing
sending the people home happy Avengers
you did it Congrats how's it going
everybody it's Warren and yesterday we
talked about the rumor that Charlie
Hunnam is being teased as the
front-runner for a future Wolverine
movie and today we're going to talk
about the rock being teased to play a
possible character in the MCU now you
may have heard this rumor going around
the rock actually recorded this video
April 28th right when Avengers in game
came out and as you just heard the rumor
comes from the rock himself saying that
he's been trying to meet with Kevin
Feige for a long time now so I'll break
down everything that's been going around
in this video but first if you're new to
my channel be sure to subscribe at the
400,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and each will get
to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection and I'll talk
more about the giveaway at the end of
the video so as you just heard in a
video that the rock recorded himself
Kevin VG's assistant and Dwayne's
assistant have been trying to get the
two together for lunch for a very long
time now so what does this mean are the
two of them getting together just to
have lunch and hang out of course it's
possible
but it's not very likely as the rock
said they're both extremely busy people
especially Kevin Feige right now with
everything going around with Avengers
endgame and the rock is in the middle of
filming a lot right now as well so in
between the two of them having very very
busy schedules the two of them are not
probably trying to meet just to hang out
they want to talk for a very specific
purpose and now everybody is speculating
and it makes a lot of sense that they
are meeting to talk about the rock to
take on an MCU character keep in mind
that Disney owns Marvel and Dwayne has
worked for Disney many many times he did
Moana which was a huge success and he's
doing Jungle Cruise right now not to
mention he's done a lot of other Disney
movies as well so he's already part of
the Disney family and we know that he's
been wanting to play a superhero role
for a while now especially with his
involvement with Shazam and Black Adam
so although this is just complete
speculation right now logically it would
make sense that Kevin Feige and the rock
would be trying to meet about a future
MCU character for the rock so who could
this MCU character be that the rock
could play well it's most likely not
going to be any character in any of the
Marvel phase four movies coming soon but
we could get him in the latter half of
phase 4 the reason I say this is because
in his video he says that their
assistants have been trying to get them
together for lunch for a while so they
clearly don't seem to be in any rush
which means he's probably not going to
be in a movie coming out soon and you
also have to take into mind the rocks
build he's a huge guy he's super
muscular which means he's going to have
to play a character that is really big
and muscular as well well there are two
characters that everybody is named
dropping right now that people think the
rock would be able to play the first
character is beta ray bill now beta ray
bill is a very big character he's just
as big and sometimes depicted as bigger
than Thor
we've already seen a Easter Egg for him
in for Ragnarok and we learned from the
writers and the producers of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in game that
they wanted to put beta ray bill in the
films but they just couldn't figure out
a good way to do it and we won't have
another Thor movie or another guardians
of the galaxy movie for some time now
which are the two movies that he would
most likely appear in so that leaves
plenty of time for Kevin and Dwayne to
schedule their lunch and the other
character that everybody is saying the
rock could possibly play is name
more named where the sub-mariner is also
depicted as a very big guy in the comics
and it has been heavily rumored that
Namor is going to enter the MCU in fact
many people think there was an Easter
Egg for him in Avengers endgame when
they mentioned an underwater earthquake
off the coast of Africa near Wakanda
possibly teasing him as the villain for
Black Panther to Namor has also been
teased by Scott Derrickson the director
of Doctor Strange 2 so Namor could also
be introduced in Doctor Strange 2
neither of these films have began
production at all which would give Kevin
Feige and Dwayne the rock Johnson time
to sit down and have lunch and talk
about a character that the rock could
play in the MCU these are the two
characters that everybody is saying the
rock could play in the MCU after this
video came out again right now it is
only speculation about what Kevin Feige
and the rock could be meaning about but
if they are in fact meeting about the
rock entering the MCU which character do
you think he should play beta ray bill
Namor or another character be sure to
let me know in the comments down below
and again at the 400,000 subscriber mark
I will be picking not one but three
winners and each of them will get to
pick one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection the winners will be
picked at complete random and if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like the video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it'd cost you
everything while crying like a baby
now you're number